[Music]
imagine the possibilities that would
come with living forever
you could spend more time with loved
ones master a variety of careers and
traveled the entire world if everyone on
earth were immortal we'd all have a
chance to recover from our mistakes and
our society could save a ton of money on
health care how close are we to
achieving it and how would longer
lifespans change the nature of our
relationships would we ever get bored of
living this is what if and here's what
would happen if humans were immortal
first things first
achieving immortality the way it's
portrayed in the movies where you can
jump off a building and live to tell the
tale
is highly unlikely however immortality
where people don't die of old age could
be right around the corner would our
planet be able to handle a population of
people with ever-expanding lifespans in
Silicon Valley there's a movement of
billionaires and biotech companies that
are developing drugs to eliminate aging
and extend healthy lifespans
indefinitely in their opinion playing
around with genetics and reducing
caloric intakes have already proven to
extend the life spans of flies worms and
mice so why couldn't it work for humans
regardless of whether these efforts are
successful the real question is are we
ready for longer lifespans
there are almost 8 billion of us on this
planet and if we all start living for
centuries on end life is gonna look a
lot different just think of the social
implications that would come along with
that for starters the idea of being
married to someone your whole life might
become a thing in the past with a
lifelong Union potentially comprising
upwards of 1,000 years together we might
start looking at marriages as a bunch of
long-term commitments we make throughout
our lives living longer would also mean
we'd all be working a lot more no
pension plan in the world would be able
to support you if you stopped working at
65 and then live to 500 longer careers
would be a blessing and a curse on the
positive side with so many skilled
workers staying in the workforce our
economy would be more productive than
ever but on the other hand if people
stayed in their positions for hundreds
of years then there'd be no room for
young people to find jobs and move up
this sort of stagnation would become a
problem in other areas like social
progression if the same old thinking
leaders from the 18th century never died
or retired from power
who's to say we'd ever be able to
progress past problems like racial
segregation even if our society found a
way to regulate itself what would the
whole immortality experience be like for
you as an individual if we had virtually
endless days ahead of us wouldn't that
take away a big part of what makes life
special there'd be less incentive to
make every day count and as a result we
might end up with a bunch of unhappy
people on our planet oh and by the way
that planets not getting any bigger it's
just going to keep getting more crowded
earth already has an overpopulation
problem and if the death rate slows to a
halt
then our resources are going to start
running out quickly suddenly the idea of
immortality doesn't seem so great after
all eventually
we wouldn't have any room for new
generations maybe we'd have to start
shipping people out to settle on other
planets but that's a topic for another
what if
[Music]